superhero movies crowded 2018 s film
release schedule not to mention the
growing number of superhero television
shows and of course the comics upon
which everything else has been based and
with more superhero media comes a higher
superhero body-count
in the season 3 finale of DC's legends
of tomorrow the time hopping team lost
the guy who brought them all together
the former Time Master rip hunter played
by Arthur Darvill the names rip hugs huh
I'm from East London
oh I'm the future hunter had spent the
entire third season obsessed with the
demon malice to the point where he was
even discharged from his job as a Time
Master it makes sense then that he met
his fate battling against that same
demon detonating a time core in order to
save his friends and sacrificing his
life in the process
unfortunately that explosion only
wounded malice but the legends were
eventually able to defeat the demon
thanks to a 12-foot teddy bear no really
considering that the entire show is
built around time travel and the
occasional alternate reality it wouldn't
be much of a stretch to see Darville
back in action in a future season in the
meantime though the legends will have to
fend for themselves
r.i.p ripped Avengers infinity war
brought a lot of death to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe claiming a higher
superhero body count than any other MCU
film to date he certainly wouldn't be
the last
but the major character with the dubious
honour of dying first was Heimdall as
played by Idris Elba having helped
Shepherd their surviving ass guardians
to safety at the end of Thor Ragnarok
Heimdall was on board the refugee ship
when Thanos and his Black Order attacked
at the start of the film he's already
seriously injured and in no position to
help Thor Loki and the Hulk and their
initial skirmish with a nose at least
not at first
presumably hoping that Bruce Banner
would warn the heroes of Earth that
Thanos was on his way I'm don't used the
last of his strength to activate the
Bifrost and send the Hulk back to earth
right before Thanos impaled him by the
time Avengers infinity war rolled around
Loki had already died twice only to
prove that he was a little more
resilient than the rest of the ass
Guardians assumed this time though it's
tough to imagine him pulling off that
same trick again after handing over the
tesseract which turned out to be an
infinity stone it seemed like Loki might
go back to his old tricks and ally
himself with Thanos just like he had
back in the first Avengers film the act
tricked everyone including Thor but it
wasn't enough to stop Thanos in the end
the mad Titan easily choked the life out
of a god of mischief considering all the
innocents who died at Loki's hands
during the battle of Manhattan not to
mention the murder of his biological
father attempted genocide of the frost
giants and various other crimes he
transformed himself into a snake and he
knows enough snakes so I went to pick up
the snake to admire it and he transforms
back into himself and he was like it's
me any stunt me it's pretty easy to
argue that Loki doesn't belong in any
list of fallen heroes that said his
actions at the end of Ragnarok and a
noble sacrifice in infinity war show
that he's more than just another
supervillain of all the deaths doled out
by Thanos in Avengers infinity war the
only one he showed any
rat 4 was the murder of his adopted
daughter Kimura after she revealed the
location of the soul stone to stop
Thanos from torturing nebula Gamora led
Thanos to the planet bore mirror on that
desolate world a ghostly apparition of
the red skull appeared to them and
explained that in order to gain the soul
stone
Thanos had to sacrifice the thing he
loved most you failed
do you wanna know why because you love
nothing much to her own surprise it
turned out the only thing Panos love was
gomorrah herself and while she tried to
kill herself before Thanos could he
threw her from a cliff to claim his
prize as someone who has an infinity
stone embedded in his head that's
keeping him alive vision was on the
chopping block from the start of
infinity war admittedly every single
being in the universe was in danger in
that movie but provision the threat was
pretty direct and evolved everyone else
doing their best to protect him
including Captain America once he learns
of Thanos his plans vision insists the
only choice was to let Scarlet Witch use
her powers to destroy the mine stone but
despite a group of Marvel Universe super
geniuses working on it
there was no way to get it out safely
when Thanos arrived in Wakanda with
every other infinity stone under his
command Scarlet Witch destroys the mine
stone killing vision in the process only
for Thanos to use the powers of the time
stone to put vision back together so
that he could take him out in his own
special mind stone extracting way
Avengers infinity war ended with a
cliffhanger so dark it made Empire
Strikes Back say do lighten up it
probably goes without saying but one of
the comics that heavily influenced
infinity war was marvel's 1991
miniseries Infinity Gauntlet in the
comic the story begins when Thanos
gathers all six Infinity stones and when
the snap of his fingers kills half the
sentient beings in the universe
including a whole lot of superheroes
which kept the cast to a relatively
manageable size
infinity war save that moment for the
conclusion and it's devastating and far
more horrific than the source material
in the comics people just blinked out of
existence an infinity war they feel
what's coming before it hits and they're
slowly erased inch by inch until there's
nothing left
by the time the credits roll we watch
Bucky Falcon Scarlet Witch Black Panther
spider-man group star-lord Drax mantis
and Doctor Strange all get erased from
the canvas of reality in the films one
and only post-credits scene we see
similar fates befall Maria Hill and Nick
Fury considering that there are already
confirmed sequels in the works for
guardians of the galaxy Black Panther
and spider-man homecoming it's a safe
bet that not all of these dusty deaths
will stick but we won't know for sure
until Avengers 4 finally hits theaters
if there were an oscar for misleading
trailers Deadpool 2 would be bringing
home at least one statue in spite of
being featured in at least one action
scene in the ads bedlam and obscure
mutants played in the film by Terry
Crews was the first of Wade Wilson's
x-force to kick the bucket he even did
it before he get to throw a single punch
in order to protect an imprisoned
teenage mutant from the bench Walt I'm
hopping cable Deadpool formed his own
x-force team with designs on an airdrop
to a prison transport convoy
unfortunately for this new crop of
heroes high speed winds blew the team
off course and safer Deadpool and Domino
the whole roster of x-force ended up
being killed
bedlam was blown face-first into the
windshield of a public bus in the darkly
hilarious carnage that followed the most
surprising death was shatter star a
longtime x-force member in the comics
shatter star was heavily featured in the
trailers but sadly wound up on the wrong
end of a helicopter and got chopped to
pieces moviegoers didn't even get to see
his cool swords they have two blades
next up on X forces list of untimely
deaths was the Vanisher he was one of
the x-men's earliest comic book villains
but when he showed up or didn't in
Deadpool 2 no one was really sure if
teleport porter the teleporting mutants
with what might be the worst name in
comics history actually existed
eventually though it turned out that he
was a full-fledged member of the team
and moviegoers got a glimpse at just who
was behind his less than visible
presence
maybe the wind can't blow really in the
comics zeitgeist is the leader of a
reality show Celebrity version of
x-force for about 5 minutes he actually
dies in the same issue where he makes
his first appearance along with most of
his team so if nothing else
Deadpool too has that bit of true to
canon accuracy going for it also
accurate his extremely gross superpower
of barfing acid the bad news well worse
news is that we only get to see that
power when zeitgeist winds up in a wood
chipper the powerless Peter tries to
save his new teammates only to get his
arm acid off by zeitgeist vomit and die
himself
that's gross enough to make you long for
helicopter blades or a speeding bus but
at least Peter was saved by Deadpool's
time hopping mini adventure at the end
when Deadpool uses cables Time Machine
to undo Vanessa and Peter's deaths in
the mid credit sequence of Deadpool 2 he
also uses it to correct some more
notorious mistakes x-men origins
Wolverine is often considered a low
point for Deadpool fans mostly because
it turned the famously talkative Wade
Wilson into a malice murderous Mortal
Kombat ripoff as much as you may hate
that movie Ryan Reynolds has shown us
that he probably hates it more paradeen
that movie's action in Deadpool 2 was
some flashy but completely ineffective
sword action
those books like super fast that still
wasn't enough though so once he gets his
hands on some time-travel deadpool's
first priority is to head back to 2009
to fire bullet after bullet into his
previous incarnation while most of
ant-man in the wasp takes place before
the events of Avengers infinity war the
post credits scenes caught up to the
Avengers ill-fated battle with Thanos in
those we learned that the original
ant-man and both women who went by the
codename wasp were victims of fan OSes
infamous snap leaving only their dust
blowing in the breeze before they set
their sights on shatter the anti-mutant
hate group called the purifiers were bad
but hadn't gone as far as murder then in
the 19th episode of the series that line
is crossed it started when disgraced
Sentinel agent Jace Turner joined the
purifiers he seemed intent on changing
their method but after finding the
location of the mutant underground base
he led an attack with lethal
consequences
Shatter volunteered to distract the
purifiers man while most of their
weapons couldn't penetrate his skin
agent Turner brought heavier ordnance
clearly conflicted but ultimately
resolved to his course Turner unloaded a
machine gun at shatter killing him
Elseworlds
the 2018 crossover that ran through the
majority of the CW's arrow first series
was highly anticipated for its
live-action debut of Ruby roses bat
woman the role reversals of Barry Allen
and Oliver Queen and Superman's black
suit
I like you better in blue the episodes
immediately preceding the crossover for
each respective participating series
ended with the same brief scene of
destruction the lifeless bodies of
superheroes scattered around a war-torn
landscape most of the corpses faces were
hidden but judging by the costumes the
dead heroes from Earth 90 included the
Ray Hawkman Hawkgirl firestorm Huntress
Captain Cold
and star girl the only survivor of Earth
90s Heroes was the flash who flees his
world before the monitor can destroy it
we don't know if the older flash
survived the crossover after he contacts
the heroes of Earth one the earth 90
flash fights beside them when they
launch a brief and futile attack on the
monitor
with just a motion of the monitors hand
earth 90 flash disappears in a cloud of
smoke and never reappears monitor uses
similar powers on other heroes without
killing them but since earth 90 no
longer exists it's unclear where
monitors sent the older flash go find
someone else to prank douchebag
probably the most blatant way the
animated film spider-man into the
spider-verse differed from the
comic-book event that inspired it is the
film doesn't have much of a body count
Marvel spider-verse crossover didn't
just introduce loads of alternate
reality versions of spider-man it killed
a whole bunch of them too obviously into
the spider-verse wanted a
family-friendly appeal that would be
spoiled by the brutal murders of dozens
of spider themed heroes but there was
one victim among its spiders Peter
Parker is dispatched by the kingpin
early in the film Miles Morales and the
other spider heroes rally at the home of
Peters Aunt May
where we learned that the late Parker
kept his own spider cave below May's
backyard shed Parker's death partly
mirrored the character's fate in the
now-defunct ultimate line of Marvel
Comics the ultimate version of Peter
Parker died while fighting the Green
Goblin and was replaced by the new
spider-man Miles Morales
your nap
[Music]